[Music]
foreign
Administration announcing student loan
relief big changes are coming for
millions of Americans with student loans
ours will be getting some release 10
after three years of a freeze on
payments it is time to start paying back
borrowers must resume paying off their
entire student loans prepare your bank
accounts to take a hit payments are
scheduled to begin with no money
forgiven at all
[Music]
thank you
hey guys I'm Dave Ramsey Welcome to our
free live stream student loan debt in
America how we got here and how we get
out
I'm standing on the debt-free stage here
in the headquarters of Ramsey Solutions
and
we have noticed like you have that a
financial tsunami is about to sweep this
nation
we have federal student loan debt our
student loan debt in total of about 1.7
trillion dollars in America right now 44
million of you have this student loan
debt and it's coming at you like a train
right now interest started up September
1 payments will start October 1. average
student loan being almost 40
000 a person
in the midst of this over the last three
years a couple of different presidential
administrations have given you the
ability to Kick the Can down the road
and then they've made a series of false
promises about student loan forgiveness
and well the results are in it's not
coming
so what are we going to do now
payments are going to restart and
everybody's going to be impacted
people are scared
some of you are really confused and some
of you are angry you expected the
Forgiveness to come and now it's not
there but either way we've got this
reality of October the 1st staring at
you and uh you're kind of having an oh
crap moment what am I going to do now I
got to get an extra job I got to get
five extra jobs how are we going to make
this work I'm in trouble this is I don't
know how we're going to do this well
last week we went on Instagram and we
asked for your questions and you know
about four million folks on Instagram so
a couple of you answered and gave us
your some questions that will weave into
this live stream tonight first one is
Nick on Instagram he said Dave these
loans just really scare me
it makes me feel it feels like they come
with a two-ton weight on my shoulders
Dr John deloney that works in the mental
health space one of our Ramsey
personalities says that the body keeps
the score you physically register stress
trauma worry it does feel like a two-ton
weight especially when you've got a a
mountain of debt in front of you that
you don't know how you're going to climb
so what are you going to do about it
well a lot of people have been stuck a
lot of people been paralyzed a lot of
been people a lot of people been sitting
on uh the bank of the dot the denial
like denial is not just a river in Egypt
hello I mean you've been putting this
off about as long as you can so what's
got people stuck in this well one thing
is they were waiting on the government
to bail them out they were hoping that
President Biden was actually going to
pull off a forgiveness uh process that
obviously the Supreme Court said no to
you can like that or not like it but
it's a reality that's where we are today
the government created this mess and the
government is not going to clean it up
for you and that's the problem and a lot
of people are stuck because they're
searching for some kind of a hack like
the Forgiveness programs I'm going to go
into the uh the you know the the private
or the public student loan forgiveness
program which is a a bloody joke here's
why it's a joke
1.6 of the people that have applied
after being in that program for 10 years
waiting on forgiveness serving doing
their career in a non-profit or an
underserved area of some kind counting
on forgiveness after paying payments for
10 years 1.6
98 out of 100 did not get it 1.6 percent
were successful
so this is not a hack
this is a problem
and another thing people are trying to
do is they're trying to get yet one more
time Kick the Can down the road with
some easier payment plans some way that
I can make the payment small which of
course means you're going to be in debt
for ever you're going to have navient or
Sally mayor God help you one of the
others in your living room for the rest
of your life guys I got to tell you
what we've been doing so far what you've
been doing so far not working for you
there's a better way
it's scary out there but facts are your
friends when you're facing something
that's overwhelming recent TransUnion
study said that 50 percent of consumers
are going to end up with a 200 or more
monthly payment twenty percent of
consumers are going to be 500 a month or
more and a lot of you're going to be
paying way more than that
so the first thing we're going to do is
we're going to say facts are your
friends open the student loan statement
open the website Find Out Who Your
servicer is about a fourth of you have a
brand new servicer out there
and that means 16 to 20 million people
somewhere in there have someone else
servicing their loan they'll win this
three-year pause started so you're going
to go find out who your servicer is
you're going to find out what your
balances are you're going to find out
what the programs are you got to gather
facts and that will lower your stress
and give you ways of doing this
student loans are not going to leave
your life
until you take action you take action no
one's going to do it no Calvary is
coming you're going to do it and we're
going to help you we're going to show
you how we're going to cheer you on 30
years of showing people how to get out
of debt on the Ramsey Show radio show
Talk Radio podcast YouTube now on stages
in Live Events uh 20 30 million books
sold now showing people how to get out
of debt we've seen people dig out of
what looked like impossible situations
but they got mad they got the facts they
got intense and they would not rest
until they put the debt behind them none
of them relied on the White House to
bail them out
they did it in their house and that's
what you're going to do you're going to
do it in your house people who build
wealth who get clear of financial
Calamity like a massive student loan
debt and go on to build wealth are
people who control the controllables
they control their own destiny and you
can do this guys I know it's scary I
know it feels like it can't be done but
we're going to show you a lot of people
that have done it we're going to show
you exactly some of the steps you can
take to get there so if you're ready to
eliminate debt so that you can build
wealth if you're ready to get your life
back we're here to help
there's no easy thing there's no
microwave this is a crock pot it's going
to cook a little while no one
accidentally wins winning is an
intentional act as a matter of fact
winning is a series of intentional act
that causes someone to be what we call
successful successful in their career
winning the Super Bowl winning the
Stanley Cup winning in your marriage
it's a series of intentional acts the
same thing here when it comes to winning
with the student loan debt mess in your
life getting it out Naomi's on Instagram
she says I feel so lost
I can't even I don't even know how to
come up with a plan well Naomi you're in
good hands one of our Ramsey
personalities Jade warshaw she and her
husband Sam they paid off hundreds of
thousands of dollars in debt and a lot
of its student loan debt she knows
exactly how you feel and she has an
experience to prove it my old Pastor
said there's a man with an experience is
not at the mercy of a man with an
opinion so Jade is the woman of the hour
to tell you about this stuff welcome
Jade warshaw thank you so much Dave wow
I'm glad to be here I'm so happy to be
here with you tonight and here's the
thing if you're watching this live
stream tonight it's because you've got
student loans and the first thing I want
to say to you is and I know what you're
feeling I know how that feels man the
anger the frustration the guilt right
the stress that you're facing knowing
that these loans are coming back and
that these payments are due in October I
know how you're feeling firsthand I mean
some of you know my story some of you
don't but my husband and I came out of
college looked up and realized that we
had 460 thousand dollars of debt of
which 280 000 of it were student loans
and I mean here's my list of debts here
Sam and I we had so many different debts
they highlighted the the student loan
ones in green but you can see here we
Sally May on there several times of
course Nelnet navient look at this one
ACS 128
000 of debt
I know how that feels private loans
federal loans and I remember one of them
this big one down here they busted it up
into lots of little debts and each of
them had a different interest rate on it
right some of you guys know exactly what
I'm talking about and some of those
interest rates were in the teens okay so
we're talking about massive payments
massive amounts of interest accruing and
can I tell you the worst part of it when
we started out we were only making
thirty thousand dollars combined income
just two musicians trying to make our
way and I'll tell you what in those
moments we thought it was absolutely
hopeless I mean we thought there was no
possible way that we could get out of
this debt and to make matters worse the
people around us they weren't telling us
anything different we had family members
say
you're gonna die with this debt there's
no point in even trying to pay it off
you'll die with it man they were wrong
and anybody telling you hey trying to
get out of student loans you know it's
there's it's pointless there's no way to
get out you need somebody to come help
you you need to depend on the government
they are wrong and you want to know how
I know they're wrong because I proved
them wrong my husband and I proved them
wrong we pay it off every single cent of
460 000 of debt yes that is close to
half a million dollars of debt and we
did it in seven and a half years now the
student loan portion the 280 thousand
dollars we did that the last three years
of our debt-free journey and guys I'm
telling you we didn't wait around on the
government there was no uh forgiveness
plan in place it didn't take 25 years
and the right Administration we took
matters into our own hands so all of the
days out there telling you that it's not
possible telling you that you're stuck
telling you you'll never be free let me
tell you something they're stealing your
hope they're stealing your future
they're stealing your autonomy to be
free last time I checked you can go out
there and you can change your own life
and I'll be honest anything else is an
insult to me and if it sounds like I'm
getting pissed it's because I am but
it's not at you I'm pissed for you I
hate when I see government systems
dangling this carrot in your face saying
hey just hang on a little bit longer and
we'll give you that forgiveness just
give me a few more votes and we'll give
you that forgiveness no ma'am no sir I
don't like that I don't like the golden
handcuffs of Public service loan
forgiveness if you just hang around for
10 years hang around for 15 years maybe
we'll be there Dave already told you
less than two percent come on that's
garbage
I don't want that I want something
better for you you know what I have an
idea here's something we can both take
on today what if we make forgiveness
what if we make freedom and forgiveness
your job
what if we just did that what if we
stopped waiting on everybody else to
come save us and you become the hero in
your story man what if you took
responsibility for your future you would
have so much Freedom not waiting for
someone else to come get you because
here's what I can tell you the system
they're not going to put you first
they've never put you first think back
they've never put you first they never
will they can't okay so here's our
moment here's our Line in the Sand we're
going to decide right now we're getting
rid of excuses because here's the thing
and let me validate this some of you
have some really good reasons right
we're looking at our our parents and
we're going how could they let me sign
up for this I was 18. okay why didn't
they stop me we're looking at uh
educational institutions and we're
saying how could they do this to me they
were supposed to lead me and guide me
we're looking at financial institutions
how could they let me sign for that
amount of debt and yes there are some
real people who did us wrong but here's
the thing we may never get what they owe
us matter of fact we're not going to get
it so what do we do do do we sit around
and wait no we take that power into our
own hands we make our freedom we make
our forgiveness go out there and forgive
yourself trust me you can do it and it's
going to be worth it so how are we going
to do this first we're going to get
organized like Dave was saying this is
your time you've all been getting the
correspondence I know they're changing
your service loan provider it used to be
navient now it's moella and then they
changed it again and you're like oh my
gosh where are my loans they're all in
different places that's okay cool out
take a deep breath open your emails up
okay call the 1-800 pay me number and
find out who's got your loan right and
then we're going to find out how much it
is okay find out who've got it now we're
finding out what are we paying and does
this payment work okay so we're going to
take a couple of questions because I
know you all have questions about Jade
I've got my payment but you know I'm
hearing about these IDR plans should I
do them so let's take a a question from
Maribel she came through from Instagram
she says Jade what's your take on the
save plan and um what are the pros and
the cons so let's talk about the save
plan
um you've probably heard the acronym IDR
which are Income driven repayment plans
and just like it sounds these payment
plans are based on the size of your
family and how much income that you're
bringing in right so you might have
heard some of these income payment plans
can drive your costs down to almost zero
dollars and you might be thinking Jade
why not do this right and the fact is a
lot of you have been it's the stats say
that four million people have recently
enrolled in these plans but let's be
honest you didn't enroll you were kind
of forced in there like cattle right you
were automatically enrolled in this plan
if you were already previously in a plan
so the question is hey should I do it
I'm in it now is it going to work for me
so in order to answer that question
let's go to this next question from
zaina she says Jade should I pay them
off ASAP talking about her student loans
or or should I make minimum payments why
or why not so let's try to tackle those
two questions at once so here's it is
Maribel zaina here's what I can tell you
these are facts and these are also
derived from my personal experience
when it comes to payments whenever you
lower the payment a lower payment equals
a longer period of having the debt okay
so remember this lower equals longer
lower payment you're having that debt
forever and I don't want you to be like
that now here's the thing
you can lower your payment say your
payment's four hundred dollars you get
it lowered to thirty six dollars and
you're like Jade I can pay Thirty thirty
six dollars a month for 25 years what's
the big deal I'll tell you what's the
big deal you still feel that debt okay
you still know somewhere in the back of
your brain that you owe the government
money and your body feels that Dr John
deloney says all the time the body keeps
the score and it's so true think about
it like this have you ever had friends
coming over to your house right or you
know you've got family members coming
over but the house is a wreck and so
you're like oh my gosh they're coming
over so what do you do you pick
everything up you slam it in the closet
you push the door closed and you're like
okay welcome everybody and you're like
sweating a little bit but you're forcing
a smile right think about it you know
what's in that closet you know it's
there and it's going to haunt you until
you go and deal with it because in the
moment that was a quick fix right and
you knew it's not a long-term solution
it was just a temporary fix and that's
what these idrs are they're not your
long-term solution think about it with
the IDR save plan what happens is you
start with twelve thousand dollars
that's just you know that Benchmark to
get in so at twelve thousand dollars
you've got to pay for ten years in order
to get forgiveness and for every
thousand more that you borrow it's
another thousand it's another year
that's added to that term so thirteen
Thousand Eleven years fourteen thousand
twelve years that's how it works that's
ridiculous because where I come from I'm
not going to insult your intelligence I
know you can get out there and earn a
thousand dollars just doing some side
hustle you could pay off a twelve
thousand dollar student loan in one year
if you put your mind to it so it's
ridiculous at the end of the day guys
what I want you to know is these student
loan programs they don't want your piece
they want your payment that's it so the
only time the only time that I would
entertain an IDR such as the save plan
is I was if as is if I was going to use
it to temporarily lower my minimum
payments right and then I'm taking all
that freed up money and I'm throwing it
at my smallest debt so I can pay it off
fast and then I'm going to repeat that
process so for instance here's a case in
point at one point Sam and I our student
loans totaled two thousand dollars a
month in payments that's a lot of money
that's almost a mortgage and so being
able to lower those payments temporarily
it helped us free up money to then focus
on all of our smallest loans and pay
them off for example that debt I showed
you that was 128 000 we had gotten it
down to ninety one thousand but the
payment was still over nine hundred
dollars a month so we got on one of
these plans and lowered it to 257
dollars and when we were able to do that
freed up a lot of cash to pay off our
smallest debt quickly that's what we
call the debt snowball we didn't want to
just get by on payments we wanted to pay
the debt off for good and that's what
we're going to help you do tonight A1 is
we're going to help you find peace in
making your minimum payment and then the
next step is we're going to help you
ultimately pay these loans off for good
and that's what I'm talking about so in
order to do that I am going to bring up
the beautiful co-host not Dave I'm
talking about Dave's daughter Rachel
Cruz best-selling author host of The
Rachel Cruz show yeah we can keep going
I know it's great it's great no oh Jay
I'm so excited about tonight I really am
and I love hearing her story I hope you
guys enjoyed that because I'm like you
are the perfect picture of Hope of
actually walking through this and
showing you guys that this is possible
and that's what we want for you tonight
you signed up you clicked on the link
and here you are and we want to be able
to empower you not just with inspiration
knowing that you can but also tactically
so Jay that's what I want to dive in
right now with you because there are
some money moves five money moves that
we want you to make to really see this
progress that's right tonight throughout
this course of this live stream we're
going to teach you how to budget that's
one we're going to teach you how to
decrease your your expenses so you can
have more money we're going to show you
how to increase your income so you can
have more money and then Rachel you're
going to go over some really low lift
things that you can do that have big big
gains and then finally I know we're
going to talk about your car payment I
know you don't want to start again
that's right that's right okay so uh
when we go to Instagram we see that from
Crystal she says that my budget is
already tights and I'm not sure how to
get more money help and this is a
legitimate problem that we're hearing
from a lot of people so Jade let's just
kick it off we're gonna kick it off with
the budget so this is not the first
smart money move that wants you to make
because the budget you guys is key and I
know that a lot of people they cringe
when they hear the word budget and they
think oh Rachel that means we can't have
any fun right that means that life is
like it's limited it's constraining I
don't want to live on a budget budgets
are for poor people right yeah people
yeah I wanna I wanna enjoy life and so
you have to get over that hump because
you have to realize that a budget is the
thing that's going to give you control
if you sign on tonight and you're
watching this I'm sure your motivation
is to get out of student loan debt and
you guys the budget is the road map to
be able to do it so the budget is so so
key and so we're going to dive in we're
going to use every dollar our budgeting
app the one that I use Jade I think you
you use every dollar and a dollar to get
out of debt that's all I'm saying yeah
so this is a great budgeting app so
we're going to use this as an example
because we want to walk you through a
real life budget to show you here's how
you get margin here's how you free up
some expenses and really get to the
nitty-gritty details so let's use this
budget as an example we're going to use
a couple let's say they have a toddler
yes and they're going to make the
average household income which is 71 000
so when you look at that after taxes
it's 57 57 800 so divided by 12 that's
2400 per paycheck that they're getting
they're making forty eight hundred
dollars a month and so we actually have
Jake over here Mr Jake he's helping us
fill out uh all of the every dollar
stuff that Jake thank you benedict for
your quick math this is gonna be great
okay so we're going to use them as an
example so for a for the starting budget
you need to know it's your income minus
all of your expenses including giving
and saving should equal zero okay so as
you see we started with giving and
you're going to go down there with some
savings up there and then this is all
the expenses you're gonna go fill out
every single thing that you spend on
throughout the month and so as you look
it's all of us and then the last bit
Jade which is hard is the debt you're
going to fill out the debt section so
this is credit card student loans car
payments any type of debt that you have
smallest to largest yes you're gonna
fill it out here and what you're going
to see is your income minus all of this
you're going to see this number and in
this example
seven almost eight hundred dollars
that's over in the red right so they are
negative that amount of money and with
that shows me Jade is a lot of people
and we hear this all the time from you
guys that you feel like your money is
just it feels out of control or you know
you're kind of scared because you're
like I don't know exactly what's going
on it's this restlessness that you feel
around money and the truth is you know
that's probably very legitimate because
this could be your situation so we don't
want to scare you and freak you out but
this is the power of a budget you guys
all these feelings you're having around
your money where you feel insecure you
don't know what's going on the thing
about the budget is you're actually
facing it head on you're seeing the
numbers you're seeing the facts which is
so important to get ahead so that first
money move we want you to make is to
create a budget and so this is an
example and then the next thing you want
to do is use the budget to get margin
which means you're going to look and say
hey where can we cut expenses which is
number two yeah before I get to number
two I just want to sympathize because
you are going to do the budget and
you're going to go oh crap I've been
overspending all this time no wonder I
have an American Express bill right
right yeah reality hits just understand
like it takes a couple of months to get
this right like the first time you're
really just guessing you're doing your
best it's going to take a couple of
months to lock in the first time Sam and
I did our budget and really wrote down
our numbers I felt worse before I felt
better right and so I just want to
acknowledge this is a process keep
walking down the road give yourself
Grace yeah for sure so budget now let's
talk about okay we've got all these
expenses let's talk about cutting
expenses now caveat because I know
Rachel as soon as I said that people
were like what are you about to cut
Jason away I'm having fun I know don't
don't take money away don't touch don't
take it but here's the thing I want you
guys to remember Rachel all this
everything we're talking about it is
temporary that is the word of the
evening this is a temporary short-term
sacrifice for a long-term game so hang
with me as I cut our budget back okay we
can do this can I say this you're gonna
see this and you're gonna be like oh
gosh but listen for a short amount of
time anyone can do anything right for a
few months you you can do this so where
are we going to start Jade well if it's
me I'm starting on the biggest budget
Buster that we all know say it with me
food
takeout groceries and 7-Eleven in Sonic
okay restaurants when it's time to get
out of debt when it's time to find peace
with our money we've got to make sure
we're not overspending and so we're
starting with this category that is the
biggest one I'm gonna cut restaurants
because they're a want not a need I'm
cutting it down to zero and I know
Rachel like it's like like hurt me but
it's convenient right as you're out and
about all of this but again you're going
to say we've done math on this so often
we get so much hate for this because
everyone's like no no eating at home is
cheaper and it may not be the most
elaborate the most wonderful meal but
for a season you can do it we say beans
and rice rice and beans here at Ramsay
and that's it you guys limited but yes
let's up groceries yeah let's put more
in groceries because the fact of the
matter is if you're never going out to
eat you're probably spending more money
eating at home and making better meals
so let's up that to 500 and already
Rachel I hear it through the
interwebster like Jade family of four
eating on 500 explica por favor Rachel
help them understand what we're doing
here well here's the deal you guys again
for a season temporarily think about
your grocery budget and I get it this is
a place that you can overspend so
quickly but where you shop is so
important there are expensive grocery
stores and then you got Aldi right you
got places that you can save so for a
season shop places like that make a list
before you go actually if you can go
online if there's a place that you can
go online and fill everything out
without extra charge or delivery fees
but to be able to say if I can do pick
up that way you can see your total even
buying store brand stuff versus branded
can I tell you amazing in my house for
my show I did this experiment just this
last week you guys four different items
I mean this is like raisins animal
crackers I mean nothing like big I did
store brands versus name brands my kids
had didn't know the difference except
for the Honey Nut Cheerios they did know
that they were like the taste different
besides that those four items and then I
did yeah and then I did the math to say
okay if we bought these twice a week
over time it was 360 dollars per year
look and that's just on those four items
you guys so think about that I mean
these little switches I know it seems
like we're nickel and diming but
wherever you can find that margin is big
and Jade I want you to share if you will
real quick I'm spontaneously no let's go
let's go but the story of you and Sam
when you were in the grocery store you
guys were on this journey yeah but y'all
were so hardcore like we're not going
over budget we set this amount of money
and the oatmeal came in oh gosh I knew
this is where you're going so let me
really quick so we were probably year
six and a half into our journey had a
little bit left to go and I mean it's
down to the wire every cent every dollar
counts and I had a grocery list I would
not enter the store without a grocery
list we're going through the aisles I
look and I notice there's a box of
oatmeal in the cart and I'm like looking
at my list like that's not supposed to
be in the cart and so I see my husband
Sam and I say hey did you put that
oatmeal in the cart he says yeah it was
me but it's just one box it's just a
couple of dollars
but is it on the list though he's like
Jade it's not on the list but I feel
like we can't and I'm like Sam it was
like one of those moments where you're
just eye to eye and you're like totally
help me understand and so we're facing
each other face off and I start to see
his eyes like glistening he's like Jade
it's just oatmeal and I'm like it's not
just oatmeal because if we start
sacrificing in this area we'll pull back
in other areas and that's how it goes
it's like a domino effect you pull back
here you pull back there and before you
know it you're not intense anymore and
before you know it that that road that
you were walking on to get debt free it
gets slower and slower and slower and so
it was one of those moments where it's
like no let's put it back and he wasn't
getting teary and Misty because of the
oatmeal no he's getting Tyrion Misty
because this matters it matters this is
emotional for us right being able to go
out and spend that's an emotional
feeling and when you tell somebody hey
take that restaurant category to zero
We're not gonna sit around and act like
that doesn't hurt We're not gonna look
Twist and Shout does not taste the same
as Oreos okay nobody's gonna act like
they do but is it worth it absolutely so
that's where we landed on that for that
season yes okay so where else can we cut
you think all right number two you guys
are subscriptions Rachel oh suggestions
Millennials on average you ready for
this you guys 17 subscriptions on
average that people the Millennials
specifically have which is wild so and
they're usually duplicates so let's go
in and look we got HBO Max and Netflix
we don't need both of those and Disney
yeah keep it we'll keep Disney for now
just because we got a little kid in this
example get rid of HBO Max get rid of
Apple music you can YouTube music and
Amazon Prime stop what you're doing
right now and delete Amazon from your
phone because y'all know you're spending
too much I'm included in that all right
what else and a lawn service oh lawn
service and that's the thing Rachel go
through because there's lots of
miscellaneous items once you make your
budget you're thinking of everything you
might spend money on and you're gonna
see a lot of things like buy your own
lawnmower on Craigslist and cut your own
grass so scroll down Jake and let's see
some of these other things that people
spend money on it is legitimate and
that's the other thing you guys about
the budget if you're filling out a
budget you want to make it realistic
right if you put zero for all these
categories that's not realistic right
make it realistic but so yeah so like
fun money can be there a little bit of
miscellaneous yes that's fine because
there's going to be stuff that comes up
throughout the month so some of this is
good but what you see up there in the
red jade is that we're almost remember
negative 800 and now it's almost you
know it's 467. we're going in the right
direction which is great but we still
have more to do so let's talk about
getting your income up right because the
the formula when you're looking at the
budget is really two factors it's your
expenses the money going out and then
the money coming in so we talked about
expenses let's talk about the money
coming in which is income income we can
look at that in two ways right there's
your core income that you make from your
main job and then there's the side
hustle right that was like the buzzword
of the last three years side hustling
right extra money coming in and let me
tell you if you make a great Court
income this is the key you need to drive
this number up up so we had extra money
not only to make your payment but
eventually pay off these debts and make
quick progress so let's take a yeah from
Brie on Instagram she says I'm a teacher
what are the best side jobs to pay off
student loans so yeah Brie's a great
example so if you're a teacher I would
automatically say can you tutor on the
side like what are things that you can
do that you already have the skill set
you're already doing maybe in your day
job that you can take and actually make
some money and I yeah talked about this
on my show as well Jay because there are
so many lucrative side hustles out there
you guys so it's everything from food
delivery service uh pet sitting
babysitting even things like jewelry
cleaning we found that people pay for
wrap your car if you're gonna be driving
companies will pay you to wrap your car
as you're driving it's amazing that's
right uh referee sports games I mean
there are so many options out there you
guys so look at those side hustles and
you and Sam you guys did a bunch as you
were getting out of town absolutely and
I'm thinking as you're saying that I'm
like obviously like your own job like
over time at your own job right for sure
or nurses you can get that overtime
that's great uh what Sam and I did is we
took the things that we were already
good at already passionate about and we
turned those into side hustles because
then you get to set your own hours set
your own pace so we were both musicians
so we did lots of different types of
music lessons my husband's great at like
technology so he did websites I love
cooking and baking so I made wedding
cakes and cupcakes and all of that stuff
so find something that you like the goal
here is we want to make between like
around twenty dollars yeah twenty
dollars an hour and again you guys
that's fair and remember this we're
gonna say we're gonna be a broken record
up here because we want to drill this in
your head temporary temporary we always
say live like no one else so later you
can live and give like no one else so
all this extra working all this cutting
expenses I know it can feel overwhelming
it's for a season okay on average 18 to
24 months what it takes for people say
that again get out of debt 18 to 24
months year and a half to two years okay
so just drill down and and really focus
on that timeline so yeah but but with
the side hustle Jade like you're saying
yes if you did 20 an hour you know 15
hours a week extra yeah the aim is to
get to a thousand dollars between you
and your spouse or if you're single just
you a thousand extra dollars after taxes
so you're able to come in here and say
okay I'm taking home a thousand dollars
here her side hustle a thousand dollars
like I feel like that is very feasible
so that's thing one now we're out of the
we're out of the red good to see you
guys we're and so fifteen hundred
dollars in the positive which is so
exciting this is where the momentum
really starts to pick up that's
excellent so we've talked about side
hustling now let's talk about the other
part of your income probably the most
important part of your income your core
income this is what you're earning from
your main job now if you're anything
like Sam and I some of us our core
income is not sustainable as it is when
Sam and I first started we were making
thirty thousand between the two of us
that's not good okay so we needed to
make steps to make it better and some of
you need to do that too it might be
looking at a completely different career
path and Ken Coleman uh one of the
personalities that we work with has such
good content on that you can check him
out it might look like certifications it
might look like moving to a place where
there's more opportunity whatever it is
you need to sit down and start tracking
a path to create a sustainable higher
core income long term and I can't stress
it enough this is long term this is
going to take some time it took Sam and
I several years really all of that seven
and a half year debt-free journey to
really get our income up to where it
needed to be so you can do that didn't
happen overnight but let's pretend that
you know the folks on our budget here
we'll call him Jack and Jane because I
just like that
they found a way to get their income up
over the Long Haul yeah let's say
they're making 15 000 more a year
combined yeah that's fair enough like we
can imagine that so if they did that'd
be about uh let's see 1207 12 750 after
taxes that they're adding to their
paycheck so that's about 530 dollars per
paycheck so Jake let's add that in I
think that's reasonable we can bring
home another 530 dollars each totally
reasonable yes and then you look up Jade
you got twenty five hundred dollars you
guys right so you're starting to see
this kick in which is so great okay next
let's look at what we call low lift big
gains so first and foremost take a deep
breath but I'm going to encourage you to
pause retirements wait a second pause
you're investing Rachel what are you
doing it's the thing everyone hates
everyone's like Rachel but it's free
money I'm getting it back from my 401k
listen what we have found is when you
can Channel all of your income as much
income as possible to one thing and you
focus all your energy all your time on
one thing you get it done that much
faster because if you pause retirement
again this is on average two years maybe
into three after all that's done and you
have a fully funded emergency fund then
you'll then you'll fund 15 of your
income into retirement so you will catch
up okay so pausing for the short term so
what we have found Jade is that on
average people are contributing about
four percent of their paycheck to
retirement so let's say they pause this
that's going to be 100 eighteen dollars
per paycheck going back into what would
you call them Jane and Jack and Jane
Jack and Jane's page okay so there they
are so we see that Rising okay so
pausing investing number two is to
adjust your withholdings if you got a
big tax refund this year
listen that is money that was sitting in
Washington maybe right now you have
money sitting in Washington that could
be in your paychecks to help you be
paying off this debt oh and it's
interest-free it's just sitting there I
know I know so adjust your withholdings
get your tax refund on average Americans
are getting about three thousand dollars
in a tax refund which means some people
are getting more some people are getting
less wow at three thousand dollars you
think about that and you divide it by
twelve divided by two paychecks that's a
hundred and twenty five dollars per
paycheck it's a lot of money that can be
put back in right so it's like all even
if it's a hundred dollars here 100 there
you guys that that changes that changes
the scenario so after you do all that
Jade look at that three thousand dollars
three thousand dollars that we have
which is so exciting and then last but
not least which we won't add numbers
here but I just would encourage you guys
to shop your insurance shopping your
insurance rates could actually save you
thousands of dollars and you know
Insurance you pay quarterly or annually
and you don't really shop right
sometimes you just kind of get plugged
in and that's right pay the bill so we
don't want you to be underinsured by any
means but go and Shop your rates from
car insurance life insurance just see
hey could I get a better rate on this
and that could save you a lot over the
Long Haul so Jay this is where this is
where the budget you guys gets
empowering because you start to see we
started in the negative remember that
that feeling and now as you start making
adjustments you're getting to actually
see this work but then the last one Jade
which is people are not gonna lie they
may like me at the end of this channel
don't log off stick with me okay I want
you to consider your car payment I know
I know here's the reason I can tell you
this I would never tell you to do
something that I have not first done
myself and here's the fact all right
Rachel yeah most people are paying
somewhere between 500 and 700 a month
for one car for just one and I know that
there's a lot of two-car family
households watching tonight so here's
what I'm saying look again I'm not going
to tell you to do something I wouldn't
do myself Sam and I used to have two
cars we had a Jeep Liberty that we paid
303 dollars a month for then we had
Hummer H3 yeah we paid 434 dollars a
month four that's over 740 a month
that's a lot of money that's more than a
student loan payment okay and all I'm
saying is some of you I don't know like
Jack and Jane right here they've got a
RAV4 and they're paying 615 dollars a
month for it a thirty ten thousand
dollar loan so they took out that's what
32 000 Weighing on your shoulders what
would happen Rachel if they said you
know what I'm done I'm gonna take this
car it doesn't matter if you're upside
down because somebody I hear the
objection yeah someone in the interwebs
is going but Jade I'm upside down on my
car payment you know I oh you know it's
I'll take a four thousand dollar hit I
would say take that hit yep take that
hit and then take you four thousand
dollars cash with it go buy something in
cash get you like a little eight you
know four thousand dollar five thousand
dollar six thousand dollar beater drive
it temporarily okay if you can't go with
one you know if you can't do one card
get you a beater for the second car but
get rid of that thirty two thousand
dollars of debt in that six hundred
dollars let it be gone and then you get
in look up you guys oh my gosh over 3
700 at this point so you're starting to
see the sacrifices that you're making
it's getting you somewhere it's not just
doing it for the sake of doing it it's
actually towards a goal and towards a
purpose because what's great about this
now Jade is you can take that almost 3
700 and let's look at the debt here so
this is an AMEX card they have the
payment's 75 a month yep and it's a
total of eight hundred and ninety
dollars well we've freed up all this you
know this income 3 600 almost 3 700 that
can be paid off right now one month paid
off so it's gone and then you go and
look at this student loan six thousand
dollar balance okay so you won't be able
to pay it fully off here but you're
gonna get close to it next month it's
gone yeah by next month it's gone so
what you got what you can start to do
when you download every dollar for free
you can start kind of playing with these
numbers which is really exciting because
start mapping it out and say okay well
how long will it take us to pay off this
set and you go down and you start to map
out and see okay how much money is
getting freed up because you don't have
these other minimum payments you're
rolling it all to the next the next set
and then let's just take it to the
extreme Jay let's just go all the way
until this example of Jack and chain
that they are debt free oh come on
here's the powerful thing is after your
emergency funds there's four thousand
dollars which means the side hustles are
over yeah you're done you can break then
you have two thousand dollars left right
because the 2000 side hustle that stops
to freed up that you can use and that
every month every month you have that
that margin and that's the power of
getting your income back that's the
power financially and mathematically
when you become debt free is that your
income is yours and we know you guys
work hard you work hard for your income
you deal with jerky bosses you deal with
people you don't like you sit in traffic
right you work hard just to have your
money being sucked out by all this debt
versus it being there at the top where
it's yours and it's all yours and you
get to decide what to do with it and
that's exactly this was a perfect
illustration of what I was saying
earlier about these idrs this is when
you get a lower minimum payment so you
get lots of extra money here you can
make that progress so fast this what we
just showed you is exactly what Sam and
I did that's exactly how we got out of
debt and I mean
it's temporary yeah you get to have the
money back and that's the best part live
like no one else so later you get to
live like no one else and we see people
doing this all the time and Jay we're
actually standing right now here at
Ramsay Solutions on the debt-free stage
so right behind us you can't see is the
radio studio and we sit there while
families or people travel from all over
and they stand on the stage should do
their debt free screams they've paid off
student loans they paid off their credit
cards and so we know that even on
Instagram we get people yes you know in
Facebook we get people messaging Us on
YouTube their story so it is so powerful
so just like cat and James for example
they paid off eighty thousand dollars in
21 months or John he paid off eighty
three thousand dollars for John you do
yeah he's great yep and then Greg
Meredith they paid off 425
000 in student loans come on he must be
a doctor or a dentist I think he's a
dentist he looks like a dentist
but yeah you guys I mean these are real
life stories that we see constantly
const so we want you to know that this
is possible but with those money moves
that we just walk through try them out
do it start the process today start
taking that first step because man it is
powerful you see that hope that you see
that it's possible right yeah and Dave I
mean you've been doing this for what 30
years so you know and you've seen these
stories and experienced this that that
it is it's so doable it's hard but it's
doable great job y'all thank you
impressive you know if you do what they
teach you what they just taught you you
start doing a budget you get the every
dollar app downloaded you're going to
feel like you got a raise
research says that you're going to save
as much as 325 dollars a month just by
being organized but we actually see that
it goes a lot further than that because
you're organized with a goal and John
Maxwell my friend says a budget is
people telling their money what to do
instead of wondering where it went
and Zig Ziglar used to say if you aim at
nothing you'll hit it every time so
that'd be the opposite of budgeting
right right let's have a Target let's
have a Target and let's not do Ready Aim
aim aim aim aim aim aim let's say Ready
Aim Fire
let's lay out what we're going to do and
go for it and knock this stuff down
you're going to feel like you got a
raise hey here's the deal try it for 90
days
and then if it doesn't work you can go
back to what you were doing that wasn't
working I mean try try something
different plug something else in right
so what we're doing is we're going to
let you have every dollar the app
completely free go to everydollar.com
student loans or use the QR code and
it'll end you right on the landing page
and you can download the every dollar
app for free get it on your phone you
and your spouse can both look at it you
can both use it you'll be able to do
everything you need to do and if you do
that tonight we're going to throw in
three other things right there on that
same landing page 14 day Money Finder
video series that Rachel did and uh it's
a great Series where you over 14 days
you find money yeah small little tasks
but yeah it frees you up it's kind of
what we talked about tonight but some of
the little little light lift things you
had on there that type of stuff and it
really frees up some money and the meal
planner and grocery savings guide is a
big deal I'm still not sure you can do
it on 500 bucks with a family of three
right now but you guys are pulling you
guys are making me a Believer but I can
tell you you won't do it if you do it on
accident that's right you got to go in
with a list you can't go to the grocery
store hungry and the kids don't get to
decide that's right you got to lay out
some rules about this because it's out
of control because the best
merchandisers in the world are grocery
stores yeah let me say this too and we
talk to families even talking to a
friend who's in this too and they're
like I'm just tired of like having the
list I want to just go in and just buy
what whatever I can and I'm like you're
so close you're going to be able to like
if you stick with it stick with it but
that grocery budget it can go over so
you know when Rachel was the year Rachel
was born uh we went completely broke and
lost everything and that was my wife her
mom Sharon's big thing she said someday
someday we're gonna make enough money
that I can go and just put whatever I
want in my buggy yeah and let me tell
you now she can
now she can't she could just fill that
buggy full and the woman is cheap and
she's still talking to it thank you for
saying thank you for saying buggy that's
such a papa Dave term
a horse and buggy so uh you do the meal
planner and the grocery savings guide
it's going to be part of the three
things we give you if you sign up for
every dollar tonight and the third one
is the audio course from Ken Coleman our
uh our career expert here at Ramsey our
Ramsey personalities guy that does all
that stuff how to increase your income
and that's a big one so we get the
income up the out go down the margin
just like they outlined for you is going
to give you the margin to be able to
attack this you can do this stuff but
you are going to have to do it no one
else is going to do it and so go to
everydollar.com student loans or scan
that QR code all of this is free
including the three extra add-ons are
free if you do it tonight that's right
okay so let's go back to some questions
because you guys showed up on Instagram
I showed up and showed out which is
great okay so let's take some of these
uh some of these questions so we have
from Jana sorry is it worth getting a
loan when you want to pursue a master's
degree so this is a big one a lot of
people look at that second secondary
education well if you want to pursue any
degree is it worth getting a loan is a
good discussion and whether it's a
master's degree or an undergrad or even
a PhD yeah the question can come and
always brings up is is it necessary
to have that degree in order to get into
the profession okay if the answer is no
then don't even go get it right now
until you've got the money to pay cash
and then you it's a luxury to add it
then it's a luxury of knowledge to add
it
um if the answer is yes now there's some
examples like for instance if you want
to be a therapist in every state in the
U.S you have to have at least a master's
level degree in social work and
psychology in order to sit for the board
and become a therapist okay so there's
some things where you have to have a
master's level a lot of accounting
programs now are requiring at a master's
level to go into the CPA
some some teacher situations are but but
most things don't require Masters that's
true yeah and so and and the same is
true with you know with your undergrad
if you have no clue what you're doing
with your undergrad then for goodness
sakes you know do I need to go into debt
from undergrad no absolutely you don't
go into debt for any of this don't put
yourself in the position that this was I
mean here's the thing you can go to
college and some people should go to
college to study a good degree at a good
place and get the knowledge and choose
something that is price sensitive and
you don't have to go to a famous college
to be successful you don't have to spend
a ton of money you don't have to go to
some ivy league thing to be successful
that is a mythology and so go to an
in-state School choose the school
carefully and you know you can go to
school debt free yeah School choices is
huge you guys I mean community colleges
and state tuition take advantage of all
of that and you're right I think what's
hard is that you know at 18
it's like you're expected to choose
something a degree and and if you don't
have guidance right people get stuck in
going to these schools they can't afford
getting a degree that they don't really
know so looking at the ROI of what
you're studying right and parents out
there that have teenagers be guiding
your student in that and then of course
scholarships grants working all of it
and going into the trades is an option
absolutely our friend Mike Rowe talks
about that a lot and I completely agree
with it we're talking to people now
going on the trades oh yeah diesel
mechanic making six figures welder
making six figures and meanwhile you got
somebody going 250 000 in debt to get a
degree in social work and they're making
38 000. see this is backward right you
don't want to do this yeah you've got to
look at the degree with a level of
practicality really the degree is not
even the answer the answer is knowledge
we got confused a few years ago and we
started telling everybody they need a
degree everybody need a degree which
what we should have been telling them is
what you needs knowledge and you can
acquire knowledge a lot of ways a lot of
places in a lot of different settings
from apprenticeships to certifications
to Community College to you know
in-state tuition you can you can acquire
knowledge and really what you need is
knowledge and really if you quit
learning after college you're done
you're not going to be successful
because lifetime Learners are the ones
that are successful yeah so make sure to
check out borrowed future this is a
documentary that it's free on YouTube
when we talk about this this whole Topic
in depth so make sure to check that out
all right the next question is from
Elizabeth how do I manage my loans while
starting a life with my fiance wedding
buying a house all the all that new
season why does that ring a bell I get
that you know you come out of college
you get married you want all the things
that you saw your parents have right you
want the cars and you want the home the
big house right with the fully furnished
you want to get all these things so
quickly but I will say there's a right
way and there's a peaceful way to go
about that and then there's a wrong way
and a stressful way to go about that and
so just like what we outlined before
it's so important to pay off your debt
first it's so important to get free and
free up that income so that you can buy
the house that you want you can save up
a good down payment so that you can buy
a house it's not taking up too much of
your monthly income 25 is what we
recommend of your take-home pay and that
house becomes a blessing it's no longer
a burden so to answer your question yes
pay off your loans first set aside a
thousand dollars you know just as an
emergency fund pay off your debt then
after that save up three to six months
of emergency fund then save up a down
payment and then you're on your way
that's right and even things like a
wedding right they're they're exciting
it's a celebratory day so you want to
enjoy it but when you're in this process
you know you may look and say okay if
we're the ones that are having to foot
the bill for the wedding we have to be
wise about that and so just like we're
saying being wise about college and
further education be wise about these
big events that are happening in your
life including your wedding so just be
mindful of that so here's a good idea
let's Force rank these things is what we
would call it and say not know but not
now yes okay not buying not buying a
house now we're going to do a wedding
that's reasonable we're going to come
out get married join hands and we're
going to attack the student loan debt
then we've got the freedom to build an
emergency fund then build a good down
payment and then move into the house
this is the right order of things well I
might have to rent renters aren't going
to hell it's not a Salvation issue so
you can rent for a little while
most people rent when they first get
married first at least for a little
while all right next from Tracy can I
negotiate remaining amount owed since
I've been paying for decades Tracy I
wish you could but if it's a federally
insured student loan the answer is no
you can't because it's federally insured
what that means is is the government has
guaranteed the bank that they're going
to get 100 of the money regardless of
whether you pay them or not or
regardless of the story or how sad it is
the bank doesn't care the loan servicer
doesn't care they're in it for the money
and if you don't believe me just try
messing with them they they will be in
they will act incompetent to keep you in
debt because they know the government is
going to pay them 100 percent if you
don't so no help there now private
student loans yes you can negotiate with
them and there's actually a company
that's been advertising with us called
why refi w r e f y you can look them up
and they will help you with private
loans they actually buy your loan at a
discount and then set you up a reduced
interest rate and put you on payments
and after you've been paying a year you
can buy the loan out from them at a
discount and so that's a good program
actually if you want to get going on it
if you've got a little cash and you want
to settle with a settle your own loans
you can do that on private but you
cannot do it on federal I'm sorry that's
what Sam and I did we were able to knock
back a significant amount of interest
that had been accruing over the years
and because it was private and they
wanted I mean they want money at the end
of the day so if you can offer them a
lump sum that it's definitely worth
trying at the end well the thing you got
to remember is that a private loan is
bankruptable yeah so if if you've been
behind and then you get caught up
they're kind of scared about whether
you're going to bankrupt on them the
public loans are not bankruptible and so
they know they're going to get their
money so no negotiation that's right all
right next is from Liz Marie is
consolidation of the loans in a single
payment worth it so we talk about this
about that consolidation in general that
we are usually kind of like against it
because a lot of people think well if I
can just move the math around move the
payments around it'll be a better deal
for me but the problem is you're not
fixing the problem which is us it's me
it's you right so so debt consolidation
usually is not a great plan but with
student loan debt it is the type of debt
that you most likely don't go back into
and so if if you need to consolidate one
type of debt student loans would be the
one to do it I think you even talked
about you told me that even Sam did this
and got a lower interest rate that's
right when you're doing your federal
student loans you can you have the
option usually coming out you've got one
chance to take them and consolidate them
so if you're watching this now and maybe
you're just graduating or because of the
pause this is your first time kind of
entering into that you want to shop
around your options right because
they're all all emailing you right
saying this is the one to do this is the
one to do don't take the first option
really look at the interest rate look at
your current interest rates and see if
on average this is going to be a better
choice for you because you only get one
shot so make sure it's a good one shoot
yourself and make sure you're lowering
your interest rate because we're in an
increasing interest environment so they
may be offering you a rate that you can
refinance and consolidate that's higher
than your current rates so don't do that
it's better to have six little ones that
have smaller rates than one big one with
a bigger rate that's right very very
good point all right next is from
Corinne I'm a stay-at-home mom and my
husband's going to help me I think pay
off the debt but I feel but all I feel
is guilt what can I do so this is a this
is a real one I mean we talk we hear
this a lot from couples if one of them
is bringing significant amount of debt
in that was Sam but here's the deal yeah
no I didn't beat him up you know what I
don't know if this was wisdom or like
just like young and ignorance and like
oh like love glasses on but I really was
like oh it's our debt like yeah it's us
like we're gonna do this together we're
taking on the world and it was very
difficult for him to let me do that
because for him it's like oh I'm
bringing this in I'm the one that's
weighing us down and I'm like no no no
no no like we have to like let that go
if you love someone like you become one
when you get married right like it's
it's no longer you and me we're us an
hour and we go through life that way and
that guilt that she's feeling is real
like I'm validating that it's real but
at the same time you have to accept when
someone says we're in this together and
I love you and I'm taking this on and
what's done is done and let's just live
in the future and live in the present
and go forward yeah because working as a
team you're going to get so much further
ahead so much further it's really hard
to win with money it's hard to get out
debt it's hard to budget it's hard to do
all this when both spouses are not in
agreement if you're married and we find
this a lot a lot of people ask how do I
get my spouse on board and so it's
everything from telling them you know
your why why are you wanting to get out
of debt why do you not want your student
loans around why do you want to budget
you know showing them a plan like
there's ways to go about it but here's
the deal at the end of the day a lot of
marriage problems you know come up
through the money cycle the money
portion of your marriage where it's not
really even the money problem it's the
marriage problem and so getting
underneath the hood even of your
marriage you guys we really encourage
you to do that and if it's you know
sitting down with a with a counselor or
you know a marriage therapist or
something but really getting to the
heart because we want your marriage to
be better in this process if you're
married and you're doing this journey
together we want your marriage to be
stronger and what's crazy is we find
that people that work together they say
it all the time they're like our
marriage is the best it's ever been and
we're like we're not teaching about
marriage we're teaching about money I'm
fighting a dragon together yeah
they're fighting it together that's
right exactly so here's the thing Karen
when when we went bankrupt Sharon and I
we were in our 20s and it was all my
fault
and so I could sit and say and I did for
a while it's all my fault it's not
Sharon's fault and I could use that to
destroy our future because that became
my shame-based identity instead I said
that's we we talked about it we worked
through it spiritually emotionally
merely and we said that's a thing that
happened the student loans are a thing
that happened and they're in the
rearview mirror the decisions in the
rearview mirror we're going to have a we
are someone who has filed bankruptcy but
we are not bankrupt people that's right
yeah we have a future and so the the
shame and the guilt goes away when you
start aiming at the future instead of
living in the past and so the decisions
made done we're married we're together
we're going to fight it going forward
it's good all right the next question is
from Kendra if we have the savings to
pay them off should we
[Laughter]
get ready
though right if you have all this
Savings in an account it's sitting there
it feels that feels safe right but Jay
do you talk about this a lot which I
love where you're like it's not even
technically your money if you owe money
it's bad math right the the math ain't
mapping right that's what they say
because you go oh man I've got fifteen
thousand dollars saved I got 30 000 in
the bank that's great but you got fifty
thousand dollars of debt so if you take
your little fifteen thousand and minus
it from your debt you're still in debt
not a negative note you got a negative
net worth so it's just an illusion okay
the fact is that savings that you've got
sitting in that cushy HSA you owe that
to someone you need to give them their
money so that you can sleep at night and
so that you can actually build a firm
foundation a good Financial setting for
yourself pay off your debt and then
you'll have the margin to actually go in
and save up three to six months of
expenses and then you'll actually have
true savings that's actually yours I
love it that's good math that's right
all right let's take our last question
from cam how can I get a parent plus
loan payment reduction if I'm separated
and barely getting by okay so Kim I
think is the obviously the parent in the
situation she separated uh for her
husband and she's a single mom I mean
she's barely getting by and we talked to
a lot of people that are in the
situation and with the parent plus loan
payment options it can be difficult
um through this program but but we're
saying like it's still worth it's so
worth it apply for a refinance yeah
apply for the consolidation process it
sets you up to maybe get into that save
program which as we've said six times is
a horrible program but it will give you
a temporary reprieve while you can get
on top of this and start to pay extra
using other means but overall the rest
of you take this as a warning Parent
Plus Loans really suck so really dumb
idea to use a parent plus loan I mean
student loans are dumb Parent Plus Loans
are double dumb okay stay away from both
of these for sure but this lady is in a
mess because she try to do something
nice for her kid and she did a good
thing a bad way and her set herself up
for a serious problem here well you guys
we are so thankful that you joined us
tonight and I can tell you from us all
standing here and this entire building
of over a thousand people that work here
at Ramsey Solutions we are cheering you
on we're here in Franklin but we we know
all over the country even all over the
world maybe even watching that this is
possible you guys we just want you to
hear that encouragement from us not just
to sit back and continue to let this
problem just Fester but we hope that
we've given you the proactive steps to
really go forward and do something with
this you guys I mean it is powerful not
just financially mathematically to
become debt free but emotionally
spiritually like what it does to change
your family tree I mean us even sitting
up here I'm like it's a generational
change even from him to me so like this
this is a powerful thing that you're
choosing Way Beyond just paying off your
debt this is a bigger story absolutely
when it comes to student loans
choose your heart
being in debt for 30 years and having no
money and retiring broke because you've
never been able to invest aggressively
because you stayed broke with debt
that's hard that's you know you chose
mediocrity at best
or you can choose a really hard two to
three year period of time you can choose
a RAV4 being sold or whatever the flip
is going on here you can choose your
heart so you need to decide which one
you want I I believe and I know from the
millions of people literally that's not
an exaggeration that we've shown how to
get out of debt that is you choose to be
the hero in your own story and you
choose to attack this Dragon you and
your spouse lock arms draw swords and
we're going to take them to the budget
and we're going to temporarily we're
going to cut so much we're going to sell
so much stuff the kids think they're
next man I mean we are getting out of
this when you do that you choose your
hard you're going to do it getting out
of debt's heart but we can guarantee
it's worth it you will never I've never
had someone call me back and go oh Dave
you know it was really hard three years
and you suck it was a horrible idea I
wish I'd never met Dave Ramsey I've
never had that happen not one time and
if you go do the hard stuff everyone's
always glad that they did no discipline
seems Pleasant at the time but it yields
a harvest of righteousness we can
guarantee this will work debt is not
your friend
these people are not your friend these
politicians on either side of the aisle
are not your friend they talk about
forgiveness of student loans they talk
about how evil they are and they
continue to make the student loans
that's intellectually dishonest they are
not your friends you and your spouse you
people in your household you're the
answer to your problem so that don't let
these people steal your paycheck anymore
don't let these incompetent greedy
student loan servicers and these
colleges who have quadrupled their dad
blame tuition don't let them own your
life it's time you take it back be the
hero and take it back we know this is
possible it's possible for you but
you're the only one that's going to
change your life we can show you how
we're here to root you on you call you
be a part of our program jump into that
every dollar app any way we can help you
we will but you're the hero you're the
one that's going to bring the energy
you're the one that's going to change
that when you make that decision it
changes everything and then you can come
here to Ramsey headquarters
stand on the debt-free stage
and do your debt-free screen
like these people
foreign
in the lobby of Ramsey Solutions on the
debt-free stage how much debt have you
paid off Paul a hundred and ten thousand
dollars seventy nine thousand a hundred
and thirty thousand two hundred and
twenty one thousand dollars a hundred
seventeen thousand eight hundred two
dollars
all student loans every dime of it with
my students whoa oh it was a game always
started chunking everything at the debt
I moved started my own business grocery
delivery I did babysitting I got a bus
driver's license just to be able to get
extra money once we made the plan it
didn't seem as insurmountable as once we
actually just got started because we
were on the same track the whole time
you know we both grew up in single
parent single income homes and so we got
to witness what the struggle was like to
make ends meet and we said we wanted
something different it's okay sucks
right now but I mean we're gonna be done
and then we get to move on and do the
next big thing and now you are count it
down let's hear it get free scream
three two two one
ladies and gentlemen
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]